six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's go to our caller from
the 805 area code
I always forget is 805 Florida Panhandle
oh then I'll be eight five zero yeah
that's you hello yeah did I interrupt
you I'm sorry
hello yes Oh 805 you're on right now 805
Oh Santa Barbara okay beautiful I was
there nag oh I wanted the Santa Barbara
courthouse beautiful building and then I
went out to a restaurant like at the tip
of the pier a seafood restaurant you
know what I'm talking about oh yeah
yes fantastic tab cakes I highly
recommend them yeah but anyhow I'm
actually currently residing in Grass
Valley Nevada County California which is
like well my bad account e borders on
stated at that like hour we don't have a
son speakerphone do you just to get that
out of the way
no no so hard to believe okay can you
hear me now
yes okay great there is so awesome yeah
Andrew yang
no I concur with most all of your views
I really like your work but there's one
thing I think you just it makes me
question where you stand because he
seems so negative on the left sometimes
they're just so fatalistic like you know
we don't have a chance or something hey
it's really depressing to me sometimes
okay let me deal with that but are you
exercising while you're on the phone no
you're not okay are you doing you're
sitting on it okay Wow all right listen
here's my thing I don't think the left
is going to lose I don't think the left
is destined to lose my pessimism
comes from the last 15 years of being
too meek and weak on a bunch of
different issues from not taking the
ground game of local politics seriously
and I'm just calling it like I see I get
people emailing me saying David and
depressed now it's not that I'm
depressed I'm just telling you the way I
see it you know make it happen all three
in the white house the house and the
Senate yeah we're not getting the Senate
in 2020 but maybe in 2022 listen I'm
gonna let you go I I'm glad I've
inspired you but your connection is
crazy I don't know if you're launching a
rocket or something but I'm gonna let
you go something going on there okay